[Music]
straight ahead
a law on crime daily a prom queen
acquitted of murdering her child
wants off probation life is precious and
it should be protected
and it should be guarded in all respects
with strong words from a judge at trial
how will he rule plus authorities are
now investigating the death of a 15 year
old
found dead in a sugar cane field as a
homicide
and the shocking legal arguments as the
battle over
the 2020 election continues this is not
a fraud case
plus defense attorneys ask a jury not to
execute a former pro baseball player
convicted of a triple murder long crime
daily covers court cases from coast to
coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm brian buckmeyer along with terry
austin
an ohio woman acquitted of murdering her
newborn baby
wants to be let off of probation early
and jeanette levy tells us why skylar
richardson's attorney believes
she's been punished enough
skylar richardson was sentenced to three
years probation for burying her baby
in her backyard she's been on
supervision now for about 14 months
and during that time her attorney says
she's been compliant and even completed
two semesters of college
without any issues i would do anything
and above that you ask and i understand
and i just wanted to say how sorry i was
that was the last time we saw richardson
at her sentencing in september 2019.
since then her attorney says she's paid
all fines
achieved a 4.0 gpa in college and looked
for another job but hasn't been hired
because she's on probation
she was acquitted of aggravated murder
and manslaughter charges
judge donald oda sentenced her for abuse
of a corpse
after she buried her newborn baby
annabelle in her parents backyard
he'll decide whether richardson's
probation will end early
i know in my heart that
if you would have made different
decisions in this case
annabelle would be here today and
i know that might be difficult for you
to hear
i think what often gets overlooked
ms richardson is just how precious
life is your life
annabelle's life skyler richardson will
appear in court on tuesday morning
for law and crime daily i'm angelette
levy
joining us as criminal defense attorney
linda kenny boden
linda thank you for joining us as always
the judge all but
said that she got away with murder when
he sentenced her to three years of
probation
was that proper for an impartial judge
and could it be a reason to reduce the
probation
well first brian i wouldn't want to miss
your first show here
with my friend terry a co-host of the
war crime daily so let me just say that
this judge is not going to let her off
probation he's gonna say he's gonna in
his mind
she's young and look by the way you
can't get a job but maybe it's because
you and your parents did
other media after you were acquitted of
the murder charges
he's gonna keep her on probation and
he's gonna let to see
what happens to let her off probation
probably she won't do anything
but remember probation in many cases for
a judge's punitive
not just rehabilitation exactly
terry the defense is arguing that in the
14 months of probation
richardson did two semesters of college
had a 4.0 gpa the last semester
she worked over 10 hours a week and but
for probation
probably would have got another job are
these reasons a judge could cut her
probation early
well listen i agree with linda but i do
think the defense is making a good
argument probation is to have you know
certain goals rehabilitation of the
defendant protecting society
and here there's no question that she is
already rehabilitated you know she's a
model citizen
and she has also gotten these excellent
exemplary grades
and she also is not a you know threat to
society so
these are good arguments whether the
judge in fact reduces it is something to
be seen
i think that the judge won't terry
you've got an update on the attack on
actor rick moranis
what are some of the details so the nypd
says they've arrested and charged a man
for sucker-punching the asher
in broad daylight officers say marquis
ventura
is believed to be the suspect seen in
the surveillance video
a man wearing an i heart new york hoodie
struck morenas in the head with a closed
fist
and knocked him to the ground the attack
happened just before 7 30 in the morning
on october 1st moranis best known for
his roles and ghostbusters
and honey i shrunk the kids he was
treated at a hospital but says he's fine
and he's grateful for the well wishes a
louisiana sheriff is now investigating
the tragic death of a 15-year-old boy
as a homicide more than a month after
his body was found in a sugar cane field
authorities say kwaiwan bobby charles
body was discovered in the shallow
waters in november 3rd his mother
reported him as missing
four days earlier to the local police
department a lawyer representing the
family is questioning why an amber alert
hadn't been issued and why information
hadn't been shared across agencies
linda initial reports from the local
police department said the cause of
death
was quote likely a drowning and the
family's independent autopsy
actually confirmed that as well now both
are still waiting for
the toxicology report but with no
other conclusion as to the manner of
death whether it was an accident
homicide or something else what other
information are we waiting for to figure
out what exactly happened to young
charles
well how about an investigation i think
there's two issues here the family's
complaining because there's no
investigation right
so you can have something somebody ends
up in in water and drowns
were they put there where he's a young
kid was he pressed down into the water
and drowned we don't know that
the um the coroner did release a report
that said there are no
pre-death injuries found on the
decedent's face at autopsy
and he said the lacerations were due to
autopsy procedure
which means what they took out some kind
of lesion on his face that he had there
if so
was it a a medical lesion was it a
lesion caused by
what could have been a fist we don't
know so that could be something else
they're waiting for brian
linda i'm glad you brought that up
because when you look at pictures of
queen charles after he died it shattered
not only my heart but so many others
it's hard not to remember the pictures
of emmett bobotel's face when he died
do you think that connection between the
mysterious death of these two young men
could be part of the reason why so many
are pushing for an investigation
on top of the lack of an amber alert
well
the investigation comes first but you
have to be really careful when you look
at pictures of somebody who has died
especially young child
because sometimes what we see is not
what the medical examiners or the
forensic pathologists have seen
and sometimes it's the horrible pictures
can be normal
exactly still ahead on law and crime
daily we'll take you
inside a courtroom where a judge grills
lawyers for a lack of evidence in an
election fraud case
and later on a fake pizza delivery ends
with the strangulation
of a past lover we'll take you through
the case gavital gavel when re-returned
opening statements in the trial of an
ohio woman accused of murdering
army veteran ashley biggs in 2012 laid
the groundwork for the trial
prosecutors say biggs and her
ex-boyfriend chad cobb
were in a custody battle over their
daughter at the time
biggs was working as a pizza delivery
driver prosecutors say cobb
and his then wife erica stefanco used
biggs's job to lure her to a closed
business with a fake order
then cobb killed her cobb pled guilty
and was sentenced to life without parole
he's agreed to testify against defanco
with no plea deal
prosecutors began the trial by showing
the jury different locations in the case
with the use of drone video they saw the
dominoes where the victim worked
the alleged crime scene and the
cornfield where the victim's body
was found inside of her car erica
stefanko made that phone call that lord
ashley gave her death evidence and
testimony will show
when she made that phone call she used a
fake name
it was approximately 11 42 at night
and she had ashley come to a business
that was closed
and not just come to that business but
come to the back door
that is what was instructed in the call
for the delivery person
ashley to come to the back door
once ashley made that delivery
went to the area she was supposed to
that's when she was confronted by chad
cobb
that is when
the zip tie was placed that is when she
was beat that is where she was thrown in
her car
the defense argued and the the victim
and the ex were in a heated custody
dispute
over their seven-year-old daughter and
chad cobb had all of the motive to want
biggs dead
2017 he's stewing
in that prison and now he's trying to
get
out from under full responsibility
because he wants to drag
somebody else down to his level
he wants to get out of prison early
he wants his sentence shortened
ladies and gentlemen this is the kind of
person that you are going
to try to evaluate
someone that
took the mother of his daughter
ambushed her beat her and strangled her
and you are going to determine
how much truth is in his statement
linda get this cop isn't getting a plea
deal to testify but two years
after he was in prison for murder
stefanko divorced him and married his
good friend and boss
christopher stefanco it wasn't until
after the divorce that
cobb began to mention erica stefanko's
involvement how do you think the defense
will use that fact in the case
well obviously they're going to say he's
making it up and if you saw him today
and brian i'm going to answer this part
with a little bit of a mask on because
the judge was wearing this mask today
she and i are like in some particle here
okay this is my thing all right i'll
take it off
okay uh but obviously he's sitting there
he's like passive aggressive he was like
even talking to the judge what judge i
just don't understand
he was jealous of the fact that she is
on with her life and she married his
best friend
and he was also probably hated her
because she was in the military and she
was strong
ashley biggs the victim and also
remember she also had a gay relationship
he is just sitting there and quite
frankly he knows he wants to get a deal
after he testifies or else
why would he be doing it except for the
fact he's a little bit um
crazy in the head absolutely now terry
this
whole case could hinge on the testimony
of a 15 year old girl
testifying about an alleged fake pizza
delivery call
used to lure the victim to her death
that she heard when she was seven years
old
that's more than half of her lifetime
and she is pretty young at the time
do you see any challenges for the
prosecution improving the case with this
young witness's testimony
oh brian i think there will be lots of
challenges you know it all boils down to
the competency
and the credibility the competency is
going to be whether or not she can
provide reliable testimony here
and the credibility obviously if the
jury is going to be able to think that
her testimony is honest and accurate
and the fact that she was you know seven
at the time
i think that's going to be difficult for
the jury to understand that she
can remember all of these years later
and that it's credible
exactly it's quite a long time for a 15
year old when we return here on loan
crime daily we'll discuss death penalty
arguments
in the case of a pro baseball player
accused of triple murder
using his own bat plus legal arguments
in an election lawsuit with lawyers
making interesting concessions
[Music]
trump campaign lawyers are taking their
election disputes to the courts
but are making some shocking concessions
in maricopa county arizona
these attorneys claimed massive fraud in
the ballots
but when they conducted their own
investigation they reportedly only
turned up quote
obvious lies and spam law and crimes
adam classfield got a hold of
the courtroom audio where trump campaign
lawyers argued their case
take a listen i i want to disclaim
very clearly like i did in the first
many allegations of fraud this is not a
fraud case
we are not alleging fraud
we're not alleging that anyone was
stealing the election to use
to these words uh our area
and this is a distinction
general and i've discussed on many
occasions
um the allegation here in what appears
to be a limited number of cases
there were good faith errors and
operations
should result in further review of
certain ballots
it is not a fraud case
and because the words we use here
after accident and the confidence in our
public systems i just want to be very
clear on the record about what we're
talking about
law and crime senior investigative
reporter adam classfield is joining me
now
adam thanks again for joining us simple
question to start us
off if the trump campaign isn't arguing
fraud
then what are we doing in court
well a lot of legal observers are asking
that very same question
they started now the case that we just
saw that was
the so-called sharpie gate case a wild
outlandish conspiracy theory that was
debunked
and claimed that trump voters had been
massively disenfranchised what we're
left with after
that concession is a handful of uh
possible errors in good faith and that
just doesn't
carry the trump campaign to overturning
the will of arizona voters
case dismissed all right help me out
here because even as a lawyer i'm
confused
you claim a harm occurred you do your
investigation you find
lies and spam but you still argue your
court in case
how'd that play out for them well there
was a very
embarrassing uh part of that hearing
where they tried to put forward a stack
of hundreds of affidavits
and they conceded that a number of these
affidavits had
false sworn statements the ones they
could not
prove were false were the ones that they
brought before the judge and the judge
basically said proving something is
proving that you cannot prove something
is false
does not make it reliable he didn't let
that in
all right so there are reports of law
firms were drawn withdrawing from these
election fraud cases before they even go
to court
and many of these cases are in
battleground states
are getting dismissed right out so
what's next for this case
well it's funny that you ask this
morning i was
getting ready to cover a case in
wisconsin and
there was it was about to go to a
hearing and the case was
mysteriously and suddenly withdrawn it
was about to go to court
they voluntarily dismissed it now this
was the case where they said
evidence will be shortly forthcoming it
wasn't forthcoming
uh tomorrow there's supposed to be
another case in another battleground
state
in pennsylvania uh that as of this
as we are speaking is set to happen
tomorrow we'll see if it actually gets
there
that is one of the cases where one of
these major law firms
order right withdrew from the case
adam thank you very much for joining us
and giving the insight to these uh
legal cases around the country thank you
for having me brian
when we come back the defense makes its
case for a former professional baseball
player convicted of three murders
will it be life in prison or the death
penalty for brandon willie martin
[Music]
a former pro baseball player is facing a
possible death sentence
after a jury convicted him of triple
homicide brandon william martin
was found guilty of slugging to death
with a baseball bat no less his father
his uncle and a security system
insulation man his defense says he's
mentally ill and should not be executed
the defendant's cousin said he noticed
changes in martin's behavior
starting after he graduated high school
yeah it was erratic behavior to where he
just
would just spurt out different things
and
disrespectful disrespectful things to
you know his parents
that they know how he grew up
i you know i i've never seen that in
them so
it just caught me call me by surprise
call me off guard
and when when brandon was around 19 you
were still
spending a lot of time with the martin
family yes sir
besides was maybe his appearance over
time his appearance got to just
what was different well you could tell
he wasn't either he wasn't sleeping
he wasn't eating he's like just losing
his weight his physique was changing
uh wasn't shaving
on cross prosecutors asked about the
defendant's reaction
when he was awarded 800 000 as a
baseball contract
you were asked how to how would you
define
friend and martin your answer was to me
brandon martin is
an outgoing spoiled brat correct
that's what he says here yes and
um would you also define him as kind of
like a mama's boy
correct so once you sign the
baseball contract he began to be more
disrespectful towards his
parents correct during the off season he
didn't come
move back with melody and michael
correct
no in fact he rented a mansion in yorba
linda
yes and you visited him in that mansion
did you not
once once would you describe that house
nice big home you know would you
estimate the square feet
maybe over 4 5 000 square feet
terry we've been following this case for
some time now what are your predictions
for the sentencing phase as we see more
and more testimony
you know it's hard to predict but i
think the defense did such an
excellent job they put on multiple
witnesses to say
that there was serious mental illness
bipolar disorder
there was schizophrenia and in fact you
know the brother testified and there you
saw the cousin testifying that
martin had some issues so i think he
will be spared the death sentence and i
think he'll probably get life yeah
linda we're asking about life and death
but is it somewhat academic considering
the governor put a moratorium on the
death penalty
how does that play out between the
moratorium
and between the appeals and everyone
before him he'll likely die of
old age even if he were to get the death
penalty
that's simply the reality of the
situation
all right linda thank you very much for
that terry i want to thank you as well
thank you for joining us here um how
about this linda
what if a new governor comes in could
that change at all for us
could the new governor put the death
penalty back on the table
sure the moratorium would be over
however when was the last person to be
executed
it just really hasn't happened and he's
at a young age and
believing it's again most people die of
old age
on death row all right so it appears
like that might be the
fate for brandon willie martin as it
comes down to this case where we're
deciding
guilt or innocence in the sentencing
phase whether or not he'll be put to
death thank you very much for joining us
here at the law and crime daily we'll
see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
you